let me explain why it's it's it's it
ruins a joke when you have to explain it
right but anyway
hopefully it is sufficient value to the
rest of you that you got some um
some community value out of it sure okay
uh
we're continuing on talking about
integration bypass today as
the heading suggests and i hope you've
made the heading by now with my black
mark ago now for me one of the things
that was most perplexing when i first
learned about integration by parts was
why it's called the integration by parts
because we know
where integration by parts comes from
rehearse it
with me if you have
some kind of function which is composed
of
the product of two other functions right
when we're differentiating
when you get presented with a product we
know this is called it's called
not a rhetorical question guys of the
product rule thank you okay
you differentiate a product imaginative
right so we use the product rule now the
product rule is most succinctly stated
as
v u dash plus u v dash but for the
purposes of getting to this
piece of knowledge in integration maybe
you remember a more helpful way to say
it might be
v and then instead of writing u dash
i'll go to leiden it says long form
notation
d u on dx that's a way of saying u dash
plus u and then how would i write v dash
d v on dx right so at this point here
you are mere millimeters away from the
statement the classic statement of
integration by parts i'm going to write
this like
sort of dicey line in here i've referred
to how dangerous it is
to do what i'm about to do before
because these d on dx's the u's and the
x and that kind of thing
they're not fractions you cannot just
categorically treat them
as fractions but under many of the
circumstances we do use them
you kind of can treat them like
fractions so i'm going to do something
here that looks like a pretty classic
thing to do
with a fraction i'm sort of going to
imagine
considering everything except you notice
how everything here
is with respect to x right i'm
differentiating with respect to x you
can see the differential operator there
if i consider everything without
this differential operator do you see
where integration bypass
leaks from now right the part that i
want
comes from integrating everything here
with respect
to x and then we do a bit of minor
rearrangements so what am i going to get
over here we take this
uh actually it's not the v du it's
classically it's the u dv
what do i write over here just that udv
right recognize this okay on the right
hand side
i've actually switched this over so i'm
going to get this when i integrate that
i just get
u v you can hear that and then what's
left over is
v d u tada integration by parts right
now the thing that always perplexed me
was if this so obviously comes from the
product rule
and it comes from yes if i uh yes of
course it is sorry i've subtracted that
i've
gotten it from the other side thank you
this so transparently comes from the
product rule from reversing the product
rule
so why don't we just call it the reverse
product rule we call the other thing the
reverse chain rule
right there are at least two reasons why
we don't call it the reverse
product rule the first one is it's not
really a rule and the second one is
it's not really about products let me
explain subheading number one
choice
[Applause]
when we have a look at the product rule
line one up here right
you can kind of do this on autopilot
you're so good at this now right like
make one you make one v doesn't matter
which one's which
in when you're differentiating something
that's two times it doesn't matter which
one's which
of course not right a product is
commutative no big deal even if we're
using the quotient rule
and you're differentiating say u divided
by v you don't really
need to think much you just got to know
which one is which and then off you go
okay but integration by part is not the
same
you get presented with some integral and
you have to choose
which one is you and which one is dv
right you remember this okay then you
take u you differentiate it you take dv
you integrate it and then off you go
filling in the rest of the pieces
okay now therefore this idea of choice
raises a question
how do we make good choices is there
like an overall strategy that would make
this
handy and easy to remember what kinds of
functions
are more suitable to choose for one or
the other now there's a really handy
acronym that goes with this some of you
have learned the one i'm talking about
i learned a particular one and then i
learned it's actually a lot more fun
backwards
so here is the word that i have in my
head that helps me remember
which function is most easy to choose
for which
i just remember the devils in the
details
okay here's my question i have to choose
one of the functions
to be u and i have to choose the other
function to be
dv now you can think about it from
either direction if you like
but if you think about which one
is dv the most obvious thing the most
easy sort of what's what i'm looking for
criterion to apply is
is this thing going to be easy to
integrate because that's what you do to
dv that's the first thing you do
integration by parts
or is it hard to integrate is it a pain
in the butt and when you think about all
of the different kinds of functions that
you know
some are like zero brain power to
integrate and other ones it's like
i will do anything to avoid integrating
these so have a think about it
what is the easiest kind of function
like literally you almost don't have to
do anything
to integrate starts with an e
the exponential function right if for
example
you're lucky enough to get something
with a base of e you don't always get it
but
your base of e it's like zero effort
right just take
whatever your e to the fx is divide by
your you know
constant coefficient up there you're
done right it's very little effort
think again what might be another
function that's very
easy to integrate not quite as easy go
like watch out for signs and that kind
of thing but still not that much trouble
trigonometry right because you're going
to be generally speaking floating
between sine
cosine sine cosine so in terms of
how much more difficult this thing gets
to handle sine and cosine are of the
same
difficulty right so these two here
what they produce is something of the
same order of difficulty the integral
is the same order of difficulty
as the thing that you chose to be dv
right if you start with an exponential
you just get another exponential it's
very similar
if you start with the trig function
you'll just get another trig function
for v
right here and here that is easy to
handle okay
now we keep on going further right some
things we don't have a choice you do end
up with them they're just a little more
hard
to integrate one baby something starts
with a a
algebra or algebraic right so if you get
a polynomial
of some kind okay you don't get
something the same order of difficulty
when you integrate it by definition it's
going to go up a power right
linear is going to turn into a quadratic
quadratic into a cubic etc
but it's not much harder right like in
fact
if you were integrating something like
the power six power seven do you really
care
if it's algebraic not that much okay so
exponentials
trigs uh algebraic functions all pretty
tidy
and then you get to this bottom part
where it's like oh no
these are a bit of an unmitigated
disaster again some of you know right
what does the i stand for
invest trig we know how to differentiate
and deal with uh and integrate and deal
with investor functions but if we
possibly can
which you can't always but if you
possibly can avoid it right
and then the last one the worst of all
the logarithms
right which shouldn't surprise you have
a look at
earlier in the list why should it be
actually exactly what you expected for
logarithms to be down the bottom of the
list
say it again generally if you've got a
log right you want to differentiate it
for me the easy way to remember is that
well it's the opposite of an exponential
right it's literally the opposite so
that's why they're on opposite ends
really easy to differentiate an absolute
pain in the butt
if you want to take these guys here so
what a pain that's why we want to avoid
these
make sense let's have a look at an
example
so i'm going to pick out some easy
examples
for you the first one is integrate x
log x okay now if you haven't got this
using a lens like this to choose which
one is dv
there are no exponentials no trig
functions inside so
fairly quickly i'm going to say the
algebraic function might be the one i
choose for
dv as you go about doing this as i buy
you a little bit of time
you might recognize this actually as a
pretty classic question that appears in
advance
if we give you a leg up right if we say
prior to this we say
differentiate this thing and then hence
integrate this
but as extension to students you don't
need that leg up right you have
integration
by parts so i bought you a little bit of
time
what did you choose as you what did you
choose as
dv this is an easy one guys we can do
this
you chose dv as x because you're going
to integrate this
in a second right that makes log x u
is that all right this is the way by the
way you don't have to write it like this
but this tends to be the way that i
write it
i have all of my primitives over on the
left and all my derivatives on the right
so u
differentiates down into d on the x
which is
one on x so that's all easy and then by
contrast
d v on dx here integrates that way and
you get v which in this case is
half x squared or x squared on two so
i'm ready to go
i've got all my pieces here's my uv
i also need my integral of v d
u so you can see where i've got that
diagonal going and it's like oh this is
so nice
because this thing here is going to give
you some nice neat cancelling so in fact
i haven't given myself quite enough
space here so what have i got here
here comes u v
is that okay and then here comes v
d u so i've got my x squared on two
one on x and off i go are you happy with
that
in fact i'm glad i'm seeing nods i'm so
happy with that
i'm just going to leave that there i
reckon you guys can take care of it from
that spot